(knocking)
- [Mark] Who's that?
- Just wait a minute, yes,
I'll be out in a second!
- [Mark] Just five minutes.
- [Tori] Ah damn...
- [Mark] So Tori, so let's start over.
So, where are you from originally?
- [Tori] I'm from Chicago.
- [Mark] Chicago. And how
long have you been out here?
- [Tori] I've been out
here for uh, 20 years.
- [Mark] 20 years.
- [Tori] Uh huh.
- [Mark] And, what's
your drug of choice here?
- Um, heroin.
- [Mark] Heroin. How long
have you been doing heroin?
- Um, 12 years.
- [Mark] 12 years.
Did you do drugs as a
kid? When you were young?
- Um, I did pot and
methamphetamine, cocaine.
- [Mark] What age did
you start with drugs?
- Uh, 15.
- [Mark] 15.
Who got you started with that?
- Uh, a boyfriend.
- [Mark] A boyfriend.
- [Tori] Yeah.
- [Mark] Did you have parents,
both parents? One parent?
- [Tori] Um, I had one parent.
I had a mother who was an
alcoholic and a drug addict.
So I would start
every day a drug addict from the get go.
- [Mark] Got it.
And what do you do for money now?
You pick pick up guys sometimes?
- [Tori] Sometimes I, um, I prostitute.
- [Mark] It's dangerous out here.
- [Tori] Yeah it is. It's very dangerous.
I've almost gotten
killed a couple of times.
- [Mark] Really?
- [Tori] Yeah.
- [Mark] How's that?
- [Tori] Um, I had some guy,
uh, I had been gang raped.
I was pulled into a um,
a um, stairwell
and was gang raped and left for dead.
Um, I had a guy hit me in
the head with a two by four
and I didn't want to go to the hospital
because I had heroin on me.
So, I just put a bandaid
on, on it and went back out,
did it again.
You know, it's a bad, it's
just a bad environment.
Dangerous, you never know
what's going to happen.
- [Mark] Yeah. Where do you stay at night?
Where do you sleep?
- [Tori] Um, wherever I can.
- [Mark] Do you have children?
- I did.
- [Mark] You put them
up for adoption?
- Um, I had,
my children were taken away from me
when they were five and seven.
Because I was a heroin addict
and then I went to prison
and I couldn't get clean.
- [Mark] Prison was for what?
- For a possession and sale of a narcotic
to an undercover cop.
- [Mark] Oh.
- If I could take it all back, I would.
- [Mark] Yeah. What's your biggest regret?
- Losing my children.
- [Mark] Losing your kids.
- Losing my kids.
- [Mark] Do you ever talk to them at all?
Never?
- No.
No, it's the biggest
regret I've had in my life.
If I could take it back, I would.
I'd start all over again.
The biggest mistake I ever
made was coming out here.
- [Mark] Have you ever been clean?
- Hmm?
- [Mark] Have you ever gotten clean?
- Um, yeah, I was clean
for a little while.
- [Mark] When you were in prison?
- When I was in prison,
and then when I got out
I went to a program,
and then I left the program
and just said fuck it, you know,
why should I stay clean, you know?
There's no reason for me to
stay clean and watch my kids.
I've lost everything, so
I really didn't care if I
lived or died, you know?
(sniffs)
- [Mark] Well, thank you
so much for talking to me.
- Thanks.
- [Mark] Do you got the camera?